I know it's early in the year, but we're already talking about our summer family trip. And you know we like to Airbnb. I know this. Well, we like to have a kitchen and I like to be able to walk out in my robe in the morning and have a cup of tea and as you call it, Jenna, I like a long runway. Yes. Well, you know, Lee is working in Oklahoma right now and we're going to come out to visit him and he got us a really nice Airbnb to stay in as a whole family. So that we could spread out, and everybody could sleep well. And then you feel like you're at home,
even though you're in a different city. Lady, I don't wanna sleep in the same room as my whole family. That's why I can't do hotels great anymore. Yeah, cause you all bunk up, and share a bathroom. Yeah, I like the space. I like a refrigerator, a real refrigerator. I like to have snacks, as you know. I do know this. Yes, I don't want to call room service. I want them right there. That's right. Yeah.
Everyone we're ladies who Airbnb, I guess, for your next adventure for your next vacation, maybe consider Airbnb. pepper sauce poured with ease. And if smoky strips of bacon make burgers better, you'll love our cheesy jalapeno and bacon quarter pounder. Get this beefy, bold, bacony, melty mouthful. Only at McDonald's for a limited time. Welcome to the second drink of The Carpet. You know, I've got some deleted scenes I want to share with you guys, but we also need to discuss some of the mail
we got on this one, lady. We got so much mail. So much. It had to do with our off-topic conversation about Game of Thrones. Because Angela, you mentioned in this breakdown that you thought Dwight would love Game of Thrones. And well, tons of you wrote in to tell us that Dwight does like Game of Thrones and even teaches Aaron Dothraki later in Andy's ancestry. I mean, of course he does, as when we got to Andy's ancestry, we discovered. My bad. Thank you for writing in.
It's one of those things people ask me all the time, what's it like to watch it all these years later? There's things that I forgot. Same. Right? Especially scenes I wasn't in. Yes. Well, thank you very much, Hailey, Bobby G., Adina, Kaitlyn, Jordan D., Ben W., Joe W.,
and many more. Many more. And Jenna, you shared that you had tried to watch two and a half episodes of Game of Thrones of season one. You did it for me, lady. But it did not go great. You did not like the opening credits. You did not like all the new, like, topography and the names of stuff you might have to learn.
You also did not like the queen or her brother, but you did like the White Walkers. I don't even remember who they are. The White Walkers? What? You don't remember the White Walkers? What are they? Are they spirits? Are they spirits? Are they people?
How can you forget? Is that the snow guy? Is the snow guy a White Walker? Yes. Oh, yeah. And they protect that weird, very, very cold light. They don't protect it so much as they just want to take over. There's a wall.
Oh, my lord. Okay. Listen. Okay. We can't go down this road again. Okay. But you did say, and I quote, do we need to start a second podcast where I rewatch Game of Thrones and we discuss it. You called it Office Ladies Do Game of Thrones. We got a lot of mail about that moment. Jennifer A. said, I would love to hear an Office Ladies Watch Game of Thrones podcast.
Please do this. Wally H. said, I was yelling at this podcast. You have to do a Game of Thrones podcast. I need that in my life. Several other people wrote in saying they would love it. One fellow said, please don't do that. Please stop talking about Game of Thrones. But I mean, I would love it. I would do it, but only if I just watch it and then discuss my reaction. I don't wanna have to research it. I don't wanna tell you where things were filmed. You don't wanna be like, okay, I've got a location for you. Exactly.
Because it's already gonna be so much for me. Although I would a little bit love to hear where they got those dragon eggs and stuff, like the props person having to make those dragon eggs and stuff, like the props person having to make the dragon eggs that the lady is protecting. So you remembered the dragon eggs, but you didn't remember what a white walker was? Well the eggs were very memorable. I mean there's some eggs that were just waiting for them to hatch for so long.
Okay, I say this, if we do this, you can pick and choose what you wanna research. You wanna find out who made the egg, where the eggs were, maybe I wanna find out, you know, where that big tree is they all like to hang out by. You don't know what I'm talking about. I have no idea what you're talking about. Okay, lastly, we have some deleted scenes to kick off this episode.
We discussed some of them in our breakdown, but we didn't play any of them. And I want to share this Kevin talking head. It's about who he thinks might have pooped on the carpet. And I want you to listen really carefully to Kevin's voice, and then we need to discuss. Okay. There's so many people with motives, even me.
Almost everyone is a suspect. Whoever did this is a genius. All right. There's no Kevin voice there. Yeah, there's Kevin voice. No, there's not. There's a little bit of Stacey in there. There's a little bit of like, I don't know. No, no, no. This is when Brian is finding Kevin's voice. I am telling you, if you listen to the beginning, it's Brian, and then he slowly pivots into Kevin. So you think this is kind of his transition period where he was finding it?
Yes. There's more deleted scenes and all of them I hear Brian. Hmm. Good catch, lady. Anyone else? Anyone else hear Brian? I like it. Don't shake me off, Sam. No, I don't. Oh, stop it. Brian, I like it. Don't shake me off, Sam.
No, I don't. Oh, stop it. Well, Angela, I also have a deleted scene for us to listen to. You mentioned it when we broke down this episode. You said that there was a lot more Dwight and Angela in the deleted scenes. And I thought that this moment in the kitchen was so sweet.
So this is when Michael has been giving Dwight a hard time about his sales record, and then Angela walks into the kitchen. They have a little moment. I want us to hear it. Okay, look, I know what you're going to say, that I'm not standing up for myself, but you know what? It's complicated.
I really don't appreciate all the badgering. You could outsell Michael any day. And then Dwight has this look on his face. He's so happy. Well, I always love then Dwight has this look on his face. He's so happy. Well, I always love it when Angela has his back, you know? Mm-hmm. Yeah.
Well, there you have it. This is a super fun episode. And now here's our breakdown of the carpet. Hey, gang, you know we like to keep our podcast PG. Well, I blew it on this one, guys. I'm sorry. So we wanted to warn you before you listen in case you're listening with your kids. Around the 20 minute mark, Angela goes off the rails.
Well, hey, wait a second. I just tell a story about an episode of Fear Factor. It's got some adult- There's no other way to tell it. There's some adult subject matter. You told it how you needed to. And you might want to put earmuffs on the kids at the 20 minute mark. Turn it down, skip five minutes ahead, whatever you need to do. And for the rest, you know, put earmuffs on the kids at the 20 minute mark. Turn it down, skip five minutes ahead,
whatever you need to do, and for the rest of you, enjoy. And sorry. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you.
Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hi, Ange. Hey, Jenna. Why are you looking at me like that? Because I have some sciatica pain in my hip.
Oh Lord, is this how we're starting today? Yeah. All right, what else you got? Well, I was trying to stretch it and you told me I had to sit down. You guys, she was kicking her leg in the air. It was comfortable. But you- It felt good.
You think you can do that for 45 minutes? I think I can, yeah. Okay, go, you go girl. I thought I could kick my leg and do this podcast at the same time, but Angela told me to sit down. I did because I didn't say it like that. I was like, A, you're going to hurt yourself.
B, I don't think I can concentrate. Why did you kick your foot up like that? All right. Well, I might need to do it midway, but let's get started. Okay, Jenna. When you do it midway, I'm going to film you and I'm going to put it on OfficeLadies.com. All right. Today we are talking about the carpet. When you do it midway, I'm gonna film you and I'm gonna put it on officeladies.com. Alright. Today we are talking about The Carpet.
Ooh. It is season two, episode 14, written by Paul Lieberstein, aka Toby, and directed by Victor Nellie Jr. Yeah. I'm gonna give you a summary. Do it. In this episode, someone leaves a gift on Michael's carpet. You could call it that.
In his office. It is soft. It is smelly. You're going to describe it? It is brown. Gross. But the question is, who done it? Michael is determined to find out.
Everyone's a suspect. He suspects everyone in the office. To keep a close eye on the office, he takes over Jim's desk, which forces Jim to go work at an empty desk right next to Kelly. And Jim quickly learns why Kelly works in the back by herself. But the biggest surprise of this episode might be that you finally see Pam and Roy getting along. They've come back from a vacation and they're
all giggly. They're giggly. They've been in the Poconos. Yeah. Which I Googled. It's only about 51 minutes from Scranton. And is it snowy? It's snowy because this was January and here are the best activities because I went down the rabbit hole of the Poconos. Now I want to go to the Poconos. It's beautiful. In the winter, here are the best activities to do in the Poconos, ready? One hour away from Scranton, snow tubing, skiing, snowboarding, a casino, snowmobile, ice skating, snow shoeing, there's a brewery and a spa.
Oh, I bet Roy went to the brewery. Yeah. I mean. I mean, yeah. That's for sure. They pretty much did that in the casino. Jim asked Pam if she did a lot of skiing and she says not really. Yes, or a little a little a little. All right. Are you ready for some fast facts? I am. And then at some point, Jenna, you'll have to let me know with your sciatica and all of that business. Yeah, I do have a gift for you. You do? Yes. And I want to share it with you right here with all of our office ladies listeners
because y'all been listening. Oh my gosh, who am I? I should tell you guys, my sister Janet from Texas has been here for a week. And so I just said, y'all been listening. Yeah, when you two get together, you get all Southern. I get very Southern. So anyway, you guys will get it.
You'll be in on the joke. And that's why I want to give it to you during a podcast. Do you want to give it to me right now before we start with fast facts? I guess we should after I've said all that. That's a big buildup. You're probably really curious. Oh, it's wrapped in bubble wrap, just like Michael's foot from the injury. Look at you with your little office callback. That's right. You guys that have been listening know that Jenna hasn't really seen Star Wars and it's okay. I've come to terms with this you guys. I don't like scary movies. This is an impasse in our friendship. What are we going to do? We don't know. So anyway, but you did say you love
Star Wars sort of memorabilia and things. You were Princess Leia for Halloween as a kid. Yeah. Right? All right. So remember my little baby Yoda? No. My crocheted baby Yoda. Stop it. Stop it. Okay. So I have to give a huge shout out to Shay.
He crocheted this. He is one of my Insta-Pal friends. His name on Instagram is, oh Shay, what is it? It's Forron Fleek. Am I saying that right? I hope so. But he heard how much you loved mine and Jenna. Oh.
He made you one. Look at him, baby Yoda. Oh my gosh. In his little crib and it's crocheted by hand. And look, it's a Christmas ornament. It's a Christmas ornament. Well, you know, two of my favorite things are Christmas decor.
And handmade Christmas stuff. You love that. And also baby things. I know. Like things are Christmas decor. And handmade Christmas stuff. You love that. And also baby things, like things made into babies. I know. Right? Baby elephant. I was just watching this movie Journey 2 with my son and they have little bitty tiny elephants on the island. The elephants are shrunk down and they're little and they're so cute when they're tiny. Well, now you have a tiny baby Yoda crochet. And that's from Shay, Jenna. Oh, Shay, thank you so much. Angela, thank you so much.
Well, Angela, I had to have one. I have a surprise for you, but I'm going to save it. Is it a scary movie you're going to make me see? I got you a severed head from a most famous, famous scary movie. I got you Freddie's glove. No, I didn't. This is not a tangible item that I'm gonna hand you,
but it is a thing I'm gonna tell you. Okay, I can't wait. Let's start with fast fact number one. I declare with full authority. Bankruptcy, no. We have reached full Mindy. The carpet is when we reach full Mindy. This is full Mindy you guys, you're gonna hear it.
You know it, it's happening. I asked Sam to make a compilation of all of the things that the character of Kelly says to Jim back in the annex to prove that we have hit full Mindy. So first of all, the hair is transformed. The hair is pretty much down, just a tiny clip, but it's fashionable. The outfit, super pink, fluffy.
Skirt. All of it. Pink lipstick. She sits on her desk. She puts her feet up. She's like, I mean, come on. She also talks about Beyonce. This is a big thing.
She talks about the color pink, she crushes on Ryan, and at the end, she breaks. Here it is in its glory, the full Mindy. Do it. I'm serious, my closet doors will not shut. Beyonce, pink the color, pink the person, hot dogs, basically anything that is awesome. Oh my God, he is so cute. Would you talk to him for me and see if he likes me?
Oh, please, Jim, please, please, Jim, please, please, please, he's so cute. I like him so much and I would do it, but I'm too shy. Please, Jim, please, please, please, please, Jim, please, please, please. please, Jim, please, please, please. There you go. Oh man, and poor Jim this episode. We'll get to that.
But come on, Beyoncé, there's a lot of Mindy here. Yes, I think this is it. Now we're gonna track and see if she stays full Mindy. Don't worry, we're not done tracking this in case you were worried. Oh yeah, I mean, if you know, next episode has a bun, we're going to let you know. I'm pretty sure in Casino Night she gets extensions. Like suddenly that we never speak of or her character never speaks of, but she's got this
gorgeous long hair in Casino Night. So we'll track that as well. All right, fast fact number two. We have a big guest star. Ken Howard shows up as Ed Truck. Now, this is the only episode where we see this character, but we refer to him a lot. He was the boss of the office before Michael, and Michael worked under him when he was a salesman. Ken Howard is a famous character actor in Hollywood. First of all, he's six feet, six inches tall. Is that insane? He's so tall.
You notice in the scene that he does with Steve that he's like kind of towering over Steve. He's a very large person. So Ken played basketball in school and he was offered a number of scholarships, but he turned them all down in favor of pursuing an acting career. And he started his career in the theater, Angela, a theater actor. What? Would you? I studied theater classes too, Jenna. You're like, Angela, it's this thing called theater. Theater actor. I mean, you know, I'm kind of a fancy theater person. Well, you know, I didn't meet Ken or share a scene with him, but our theater bond was
felt. Did you study like dialects in your acting theater school? I see what you're doing there. Oh, do you? That was a dig. You know what? I see what you're doing. You're digging. All right, well, he won a Tony award. He appeared in over a hundred movies and television series
during his 47 year career. Unfortunately, Ken passed away in 2016, but he left behind this huge legacy. You know, he was even the president of the Screen Actors Guild Union for four years. So he is, guys, just an icon of the entertainment industry, and we were so lucky to have him for just this one scene. Oh, it was huge. We were thrilled, thrilled. So Angela, Fast Fact number three is my surprise to you. Oh, okay. Are you ready for it? I don't know.
I watched Game of Thrones. What? What? That's right. What episode? The first two and a half episodes. Did you really? Yeah.
I couldn't turn it off. Do you like it? I have a lot of thoughts. Oh, no. Do you want my thoughts? Yes. Okay. So, first of all, episode one of Game of Thrones.
Okay. Very horror movie, Angela. The White Walkers and the dismembered bodies. Oh, oh. Love that. I know. I was like, why didn't she tell me about this part? I'm in.
I thought you knew about the White Walkers. Jenna, we called my cat Otter the White Walker. I didn't know what that meant. I don't know what that means. It's because he was so old. He was like 22 years old and he barely had any fur left. And he'd be like, meh. And we called him the White Walker.
Well, I liked the opening. Then we cut to the credit sequence, which is going over this map of lands and names of lands. And I was just like, this is the part I don't want to learn. OK, that part is long. And just skip past it. And also as seasons change and the topography changes, those images change.
But anyway, just skip over it. Then I want to say, there's a lot of brother sister love. Listen, in the beginning. Just a lot. In the beginning. And then I think that kind of tapers off a little bit. Okay. Jenna, listen, there's some messed up stuff. Okay. Well, I'm liking the, is it the Stark family?
Yes. Lord Stark. Yes. And his family. I'm digging on them. Oh, okay. I'm hating the queen and her brother. Oh, yeah, I know. Yes. Lord Stark. Yes. And his family. I'm digging on them. Oh, okay. I'm hating the Queen and her brother. Oh yeah. I know. Ooh. The Lannisters. Ooh, the Lannisters. Is that their name? Okay. But here's my big observation. Okay. And I want you to help me out here. This is fantasy, right? This is not based on anything. No, Game of Thrones
is just fantasy. Yeah. Okay. Here's my beef. Okay, you're only two episodes in. Go on. Two and a half. Here's my beef. That's why I want you to speak to this for me. Okay. Why can't the women do more than so and marry? Oh, they do.
They're going to do a lot more. Okay. I'm just saying that like you take the Wonder Woman thing, right? And it's fantasy. And so it's about like a badass island of women warriors because we can make up anything we want. It's not based in any real time period. So why does fantasy as a genre in general
seem to put men and women in such traditional roles? Basically, especially for Game of Thrones, I mean, you guys out there that have watched it now, this is kind of a little bit of a subtle hint, but she's not going to get it. So you know, just ignore, ignore. The women pretty much end up burning it all to the ground. They are literally like, I am woman! They serve it up, lady.
Don't you worry. All right. They're going to dish it out. I really hope that that girl, the girl who loves the sword play, that's a- Aria? Oh yeah, trust me. Okay, hold on. Aria's gonna do, Aria's gonna be okay.
Aria has a list, I'm not even gonna get into it. Ooh, wait, whoa, wait, wait, she has a list? You don't wanna be on her list. You know, you know I love a list. Oh, honey, you don't wanna be on this list. Ooh, I can't wait for Aria's list. Oh, it's good. Okay.
I wanna say one last thing, and we can cut this out if this goes on too long. I want to just say one last thing. Winter is coming. We get it. It's coming, guys. I mean, how many times per episode do they need to say winter is coming?
And also, this winter, it's like, I feel like they have the wrong name for it. It doesn't sound like a winter is coming. It sounds like an avalanche is coming to bury you for seven years in cold. It's an avalanche of dead walking people, okay? I mean, they're coming. That's what's coming?
The white walkers are coming. So the white walkers come with winter, but the white walkers aren't affected by winter? Jenna, I'm not gonna get into it. I'm not gonna get into it. I'm not gonna get into it. I mean, that's not what I'm saying. It's like so many things. All I'm saying is winter is coming
is a layered metaphor, okay? It's not just the cold. Oh, okay. Okay. All right, well, good. And the Dothraki's, am I saying it right? The Dothraki's, yeah. And Carl Drago?
Yeah. Is this named Carl? No, it's Cal. Oh, Cal. I love that you thought that the guy that speaks no English and is shirtless on a horse was named Carl. I did. Khaleesi and Carl, they're going to make a happy pair.
Look at him riding off in the sunset. Carl, I was like, Carl, they only refer to him by his first and last name all the time. I have noticed that in two and a half episodes, he has only said the word no three times. It's because Carl can't speak English, Jenna. Okay. Well, that was it. Thank you for watching. That was it.
I gave in. I did it. I watched it. I'm a little bit hooked. Okay, good. You'll love all the White Walker stuff. Okay, I now, I guess, have to watch, what's it, The Edge with you?
The Edge. The Edge. Have you never seen The Edge? We already, you already know this. But you've never seen it? How many different ways do you want me to tell you I haven't seen it? You know about the bear.
How do you know about the bear? I've seen trailers. I've seen, you know what? All I needed to see was a man like getting attacked by a bear. And I'm like, I'm out. Also, Leo- So the Revenant was not for you either. Oh, hell no. Academy Award winning film, The Revenant.
Oh, hell no. Another great survivalist film for all you survivalists out there. I saw a trailer and what's his name? Leo DiCaprio is getting mauled by a bear and he's like, pass, hard pass. All right. Well, you know I like quotes from things and I really appreciated this quote from Game of Thrones. I love that we're still talking about it. Go. The man who passes the sentence should swing the sword. Oh yeah. I liked that. And he made his son cut off that guy's head.
No, he made him watch as he cut off the head. Well, eventually he makes him cut off someone's head. Wow. Spoiler alert. A bunch of people are going to lose their heads. It's part of life back then. OK, back then in fantasy land. There you go, guys.
That was my fast fact number three. I promise after this break, we will begin talking about the office again, specifically The Carpet. We will break down the episode for you. I think Dwight would have loved Game of Thrones. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. I think him and Angela would have watched it.
You guys would have spoken to one another in Dothraki. Oh, for sure. It would be like our code language. You have a somewhat Dothrakian relationship. A bit of a Cal-Khaleesi thing. You mean Carl? All right, let's go to break. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp.
And this month, BetterHelp is giving you the biggest discount on starting therapy that they have ever offered on our show, with 90% off your first week. So here's how it works with BetterHelp you can pay a flat fee for weekly sessions and that's going to save you big time on cost and time because therapy should feel accessible and with online therapy you get quality care at a price that makes sense. And with over 30,000 therapists BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform and has served over 5 million people globally.
And it's convenient. You can join a session with a click of the button and it helps you to fit therapy into your busy life. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Your well-being is worth it. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 90% off your first week.
That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. With the FIZ loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with Fizz. Switch today. Conditions apply.
Details at Fizz.ca. When the frustration grows and the doubts start to creep in, we all need someone who has our back to tell us we'll be okay, to remind us of our ability to believe. Because their belief in us transfers to self belief and reminds us of all that we're capable of. We all need someone to make us believe. Hashtag, you got this. Okay, we're back from break.
We start this episode with a cold open. Pam is on vacation. Yes. Ryan is at the reception desk and Jim keeps glancing up at Ryan and he's like, what are you looking at? And Ryan has that great talking head where he's like, Jim keeps looking over at reception. But it's not as creepy as the way Michael's looking at him. Yes, exactly.
Okay, so the episode starts and Pam is back from vacation. She's happy. She's at front reception. Michael walks in and calls her Spamster. Yeah. He hasn't done this bit in a while where he takes her name and smashes it with other things and she's like, let me guess how you got that Pam, Spam and Hamster. Spamster.
And then as he walks off, he goes, I am Pam Spicoli. You guys, for you young people, he's pretending to be Jeff Spicoli from Fast Times at Ridgemont High. Yeah, that's a dated reference. That is a dated reference. Michael goes in his office, what happens, Jenna? There's something very smelly on the carpet in his office.
What I love about this is we don't ever show you too much of it. You see a little bit on the carpet in his office. What I love about this is we don't ever show you too much of it. You see a little bit on the carpet though, and what you see is foul. Yeah. It is so gross. It's pretty awful. And he makes a bunch of people come into the office to see what it is.
We had a fan question from David Griffiths and Haley Crook and many others. They wanted to know, was there anything in the office that made it actually smell so that we were having authentic reactions? No. That is just some good acting right there. Real good acting.
As I watched this, I was so impressed. I was so impressed. I actually texted Brian and I was like, I want you to go back and rewatch the carpet. When you get a whiff of whatever it is, it made me laugh so hard. I was like, I want you to go back and rewatch the carpet. When you get a whiff of whatever it is, it made me laugh so hard. I was like, he did such a great job. And Michael has a line, you guys,
I feel like is sort of my vernacular, like the way I would talk. He says, there is a stink in there. That is how you would describe it. There's a stink y'all. And I love Creed's line. A lot of fans pointed this out. Someone making soup.
Somebody making soup. So my sister Janet was visiting and watched this episode with me. She made me screen grab Phyllis's face reaction to when Creed says, somebody making soup. Seriously, it is hilarious. It's at three minutes, 10 seconds. Somebody making soup.
Look at Phyllis's face. Next we have Michael's talking head where he's talking about fear factor and he has to leave. And then for the rest of the episode, we're clearing out his office. I did a deep dive on fear factor. Why, Jenna? Why did I do a deep dive? I don't know. This has started to happen to us, where something's mentioned in an episode, and then we spend hours watching clips or researching things on websites. My gosh. It was like you watching all the videos of the Hooters' birthdays. Yeah.
I watched these Fear Factor clips. You guys, it was like, okay, eat this dried horse rectum. I'm not kidding. Yeah. I'm not kidding. Or intestine or something. And then I looked up why it got canceled. Okay. I'm not kidding. Yeah. Or intestine or something. And then I looked up why it got canceled. Okay. It's so gross. What happened?
I don't even think we can see it here. What happened? They had. It got canceled because of an incident? Yes. And they didn't air it, but it's why it got canceled. And Joe Rogan has talked about it. It's so gross.
What? Okay. You had two choices. This episode is called the Hee Haw episode. You could drink donkey pee or donkey semen. That is horrible, Jenna. That is horrible. Did they do it?
They did it. Oh! They did it. And one guy said as he started drinking, he vomited back in his own cup. Oh, God. It's horrible. Oh, my God. It's horrible. Oh my god. It's horrible. This was and how how did this get I mean who was like yeah that's a great idea that's also how did they get
the donkey jizz? Oh oh Angela. I'm sorry it's my first thought. Whose job was that? Wow. What job was that? Wow. Mm-hmm. No. No. No. I don't think so. No, not happening.
Next up in the episode, wow, sorry, did everyone do it? Or just, like, what happens if you don't do it? You're out? I don't know, like, I know there, you know, there's the contest and if you do it, ultimately, whatever all the challenges are, I don't know how people get picked,
but whoever does the challenge, if they don't do it, they're out. It was a crazy show, crazy. All right, I'm looking in the booth where Sam and Cody are sitting and everyone. They seem sad. I've ruined their day. You guys, I just, well, like this was such a big deal for Michael to, like, be like, this is
my Fear Factor audition tape. I was like, oh yeah, what was that show again? I just started looking it up. That was, like, one of the first things that came up. Anyway, you're welcome. Where are we? So next up, Jim enters. He asks about Pam's vacation.
He is so excited that she's back at the reception desk. But then we reveal that Roy and Daryl are also upstairs and that Roy is, they're cleaning out Michael's office. They're gonna replace the carpet basically. And Pam and Roy are clearly on good terms. They're like giggly. They're giggly and Roy is like engaging with her. You know what I mean?
He like looks over and mouth the word help, you know, cause he's got to go do this gross job and she laughs. So they're being kind of flirty and sweet and Jim clocks it right away. We had a fan question from Jamie Boggs, why on earth are the warehouse guys changing the carpet? How is that in their job description? I kind of agree, but it makes sense to me. I feel like Michael makes people do things outside of their job description all the time. And so we kind of had to do this too, just as a writing convention, we needed
a reason for Roy to be upstairs for this whole episode. So we kind of need him to change the carpet. But a lot of people asked, did they really rip up and replace the carpet? Well, they did really rip it up. But I don't think they really replaced it. I think they just put it back down again in the end. Yeah, I think there was like a top carpet they pulled up. Yeah. But then they, yeah, exactly. Yeah, so, but they did. I mean, they really did dismantle the office in the middle of this shooting.
Yes, and all of Michael's talking heads take place in the conference room. All of his stuff is piled behind him. Yes. So that's sort of a new spot where we see Michael. That was a fan question too from Alexandra. What is the room Michael has his talking heads in while his carpet is being cleaned? It's the conference room. I was curious too and so I zoomed in on the scene where Michael is talking and I realized it was the conference room because the painting is hanging on the wall behind him.
It was the painting that was always in the conference room. I felt like that was a nice little touch to let the audience know where he was. At one point, it actually falls down. I noticed that. As they were banging around. That was a blooper. That was a blooper. That was not intended.
But it was a great just like kind of reminder like where he was. So next up, Michael takes over Jim's desk, forcing Jim into the annex. He's going to sit next to Kelly. She explains that Toby used to sit there, but he had to move due to an allergy. To the desk. To the annex. He's going to sit next to Kelly. She explains that Toby used to sit there, but he had to move due to an allergy. To the desk. To the desk. His allergy was to the desk. I'm pretty sure all those desks are the same desk, but Toby just had a specific allergy to that one. So then we have Michael in the bullpen, and he's chatting with Dwight. They're kind of talking about the old days. They start talking about Ed Truck, and you see that great flashback photo.
And the mullet haircut. Yeah. Also at five minutes, 12 seconds, Dwight is so happy that Michael is gonna be sitting next to him. He is just so thrilled. And I watched the deleted scenes for this episode, and there's a really cute talking head
where Dwight is like, this is just a gift. The woman I'm dating might say it's a gift from God, but I don't know about that. And it cuts to me. But there are some great deleted scenes for this episode. If you have the DVDs and I have a talking head, Kevin has a really funny one. There's a deleted scene, you guys, where Jim is looking up the hotel where Pam and Roy stayed in the Poconos. Oh, that's a little depressing. I know. And Kelly's like, what are you looking at?
There's also a deleted scene where he's eating alone in his car. Oh yeah, because he can't find anywhere to eat. Exactly, exactly. But there is some really sweet Dwight Angela little nods to that relationship in the deleted scenes. And also during this whole Dwight-Michael moment, we learn that Dwight is sitting where Todd Packer used to sit,
and Michael is sitting in his old desk, because Ed Trek would have been in his office. So Michael is having a little bit of like reliving the glory days of when he was out on the floor as salesman. Yes. I think we have some real Stanley sass in this episode. Stanley sass. Yes, at seven minutes, one second, Michael bugs Stanley.
And Stanley is on the phone. And this is what Stanley says to him. I just loved it. Leslie David Baker did such an amazing job. What is it that you need right now that can't wait until I'm off the phone with a customer? I was like, there's some Stanley sass. So Michael is now walking around the bullpen and he's just really misbehaving. He's like acting out in some way. He thinks maybe
they were all in on it, but yet also I think he's trying to live his glory days. He just punches the heck out of Creed. Oh, I loved Creed's reaction to that though. It was so earnest. It's like one of the few times he's truly earnest. He's like, ow, why'd you hit me, Michael? Like it actually really hurt him. And Michael, as he punched him, yelled, Charlie horse. He's like a kid on a playground, basically. He's like a bad kid on a playground,
but that's not a Charlie horse. Punching someone isn't a Charlie horse. You know what a Charlie horse is. That's just when your muscle seizes up? Well, yeah, but I think what he's trying to say is like, how does a horse bite an apple? Wait, what? Stop. Stop the podcast.
What? How's a horse bite an apple? Is that like Charlie horse just hitting someone or is he hitting someone to give him a Charlie horse? What is how's a horse bite an apple? Come over here. I'll show you. No, no, no, no, no.
Explain. What is this? This is a thing you do to a person on a playground is called how's a horse bite an apple? Yeah, how's a horse bite an apple? Come over here, I'll show you. No, no, no, no, no. Explain. What is this? This is a thing you do to a person on a playground is called how's a horse bite an apple? Yeah, how's a horse bite an apple? I'm gonna show you. I'm scared. What are you reaching for right now? You're reaching for what?
My arm, my hand? What are you reaching for? I'm not that strong. It's not gonna hurt that bad. If Josh did it to you, he has strong hands. Okay, what am I doing? What am I handing you? You gotta slide over here.
Slide over to what? My chair. Why? What are you touching? Okay, back up. What? What are I doing? What am I handing you? You gotta slide over here. Slide over to what? My chair. Why? What are you touching? Okay, back up. What? Don't do, what are you doing?
It's not gonna hurt that bad. How's a horse bite an apple? What? Oh, that thing where you just like, where you squeeze someone's knee. The top of their knee and that two little spots that really hurt. I don't think that hurts. I think that's tickly. That's how a horse bites an apple.
Am I right, Sam? I've never heard how a horse bites an apple. What is going on, St. Louis? St. Louis. St. Louis, you check. Back me up. Where I was raised. Do we have horses that bite the apple?
This, come on. I don't know how to react to it. Sam. Sam seems to have heard this. Yeah, that made its way to Wisconsin. Wisconsin has How's a Horse Bites an Apple. Cody, where are you from? Have you heard it? I'm from here, but my grandma was from Kansas and my grandpa was from Tennessee and I've
never heard that. Thank you. Okay. So Missouri, Kansas and Tennessee, we don't know this horse bites and apple business. Well, Texas and Wisconsin do. This is based on a poll of four people, by the way. We've declared things about major regions of the United States based on a four-person poll.
That seems, I think that's kind of how polling is done though. Oh, let's not go there. Okay. Well, Charlie horse is just when your muscle seizes up. I know that, but I kind of felt like it was like one of those things where Michael gets it a little wrong. Like, he's like, Charlie horse, but I was like, Oh, did he mean, how's a horse bite an apple?
But probably not because that's too many words and he had to cross the whole room really quickly. Um, well, Michael also gets Dwight to go over to accounting and dump their stuff all over the ground. We had a fan question from Alan three. How many times did Stephen Rain mess up the accounting area? Did they do it randomly or was it choreographed? Angela, can you give us some insight? We did it a few times and you know so every time Michael would say, okay let's send up accounting, old-fashioned raid, sells on accounting, they would come over, they'd dump all
of our stuff on the floor. I did love that Angela glares at Dwight like don't even. And so he sort of giggles and picks up one pencil and throws it on the floor of mine. But yeah, we did that a few times and they were just really truly just look like Steve and Rain were having fun because they got to come over and mess with us. And then so after you shoot a scene like that and they mess up the area, they say cut. Did the set decorators come over and reset everything? They do because they want the continuity to match. Yeah.
And obviously we would pick up stuff as well, but sometimes we would get in the way. We would start to pick it up and they'd be like, here, let me set that. Because that is their job to make sure it looks exactly like it did before. And I might not get it right. So I remember sometimes before scenes like this, our script supervisor, Veda, she is
the person who was in charge of continuity on the show. She would come over and take a picture of the desk area as a reference point. So they could match it each time. Yes. And then after it got all messed up, then Veda would come over with her computer and she'd be like, okay, so this is exactly where the cup was and this is where this was and everything. And they would reset the whole thing to Veda's picture and mess it up again. Yes. Veda was amazing and she was so sweet and kind and soft spoken. And sometimes she would just
walk up to you and be like, um, Angela, and on the second line in the scene, you switched your coffee mug from your left hand to your right hand. I'm like, oh my God, did I? I didn't even realize, yes. So you have to do that every time now. Yes, I remember that. I remember that. At eight minutes, 55 seconds, I'm calling this the fan catch of the day. What is it?
It is by Biro. If you freeze and zoom in on Angela's computer, ooh, you can see a Post-it note that says, quote, Angela, can I have $5 petty cash to buy some more jelly beans? I'll give you back any change. Thanks, Pam. Catch of the day. That is fantastic. I loved that.
Applause. I think I really wrote that post-it note. You probably did. You probably passed it to me in the background because we were bored and I stuck it there. So then Michael has a talking head about former manager Ed Truck. And this has one of my favorite Michael quotes. I told myself if I was ever manager, people would laugh when they saw me coming and applaud when I walked away.
Mission accomplished. Yeah, way to go. I just want to call out one scene, you guys. I know we're jumping around a little, but it's one I absolutely love at 9 minutes 55 seconds. It made me laugh so hard when Dwight is trying to be the 107th caller. Yes! To win a DVD box set.
Of Jethro Tull. Yes! From Rock 107. And he just keeps calling. And Michael's pained expression. And then Dwight trying to sneak the call. All of it just cracked me up. One of the fun dynamics about the Michael and Dwight relationship is that it gives Steve
an opportunity to play the straight man. Yeah. And he's a very funny straight man. And so a lot of times he's the funny guy. And the rest of us are the straight man to Steve. But I love this dynamic shift that happens with Michael and Dwight scenes. I do too. I want you to know I did a little bit of a deep dive for Rock 107. I knew you would. I almost did. But you know what I did instead?
What? I listened to Jethro Tull. Oh, there you go. I downloaded the greatest hits and listened to it and my daughter Isabel was like, what is that? Well, they currently run contests via their freeloaders club. And you can sign up with your email at rock107.com and they give away, quote, dozens of prizes each month.
Here's a list of things you can win. Okay. iPads, waterpark tickets, concert tickets, gas and grocery gifts, and snow tube passes. Maybe for the Poconos? Maybe. Those are great gifts, though. I know. Way to go, Rock 107.
It seems like instead of doing these live contests on the air where you have to call in like Dwight did, you can just sign up with your email and you're automatically entered. So just giving a plug for that giveaway, Rock 107. Way to go. I have 10 minutes, 44 seconds. Okay. Pam and Roy are flirting at reception and Jim is watching her in the kitchen.
He tries to go to the annex, but he sees Kelly. Then he goes to the bathroom. With his coffee mug. Yeah. This is how trapped he is. One way is Pam and Roy, the other way it's Kelly chatty chatty chatty. So he just walks in the bathroom with his coffee mug.
Yeah. And later he can't eat in the lunch room because Pam's sitting in there with Roy. This leads to the deleted scene you were talking about. Him eating alone in his car. Yeah. Poor Jim, guys, poor Jim. Poor Jim.
So then at 11 minutes, seven seconds, Michael goes back to accounting and he's like, hey guys, and I'm really snarky. This is like very Angela Martin snarky moment. I'm like, we haven't finished getting things in order from your last visit. And he's like, I'm just walking around and I go, were you? Like, I'm so ticked off.
You're so mad. Well, this is when Michael gets this big idea to host a sales contest. Well, listen, because he says we're all there working for the weekend, but you know what? He's working for the week. What? Working for the week. He's working for the week, and he wants the sales contest now. And the prize is a $100 bill. Not really. Until he opens his wallet and he only has $83. Wait Jenna, before we get into the sales competition, I do have some journal entries from this. When do you want them? Do you want them
now? No. Do you want them now? I say now. Now, not leos. Okay. Here's my journal entry for the carpet. I was really excited. I was like, I wrote this on January 26, 2006. We got great news. We're coming back for season three. Is this the episode where we found out? Yes. Oh my gosh. So we were so excited, all of us. I don't know if you can tell in watching the episode, but we just found out we got another job for another year. That is such, that's a fast fact, Angela, right there.
Oh, well, I liked your Game of Thrones fast fact. But there, that I guess is a fast fact. Also, I said that we're just so excited. We're really proud of the show. We're so excited to get a third year. I said this week also, we had a photographer from NBC taking official photos for the website for Valentine's Day. I remember those photos.
These are sort of some iconic photos that are out there on the internet of like Steve holding up a heart and Kate Flannery and you and me and Phyllis all surrounding him. So there's some great Valentine's shot. There's one of like Dwight and I side by side. I did some photos with David Denman as Roy. So some Pam and Roy Valentine's shots as well. And I also wrote, this was the first time the supporting cast were included in one of
these big photo shoots and we were all so excited. I remember that. Because we weren't series regular the last time we did them. But now we were and we got to be in the pictures. And I said, of course, I had the biggest zit since I've had since high school. Yeah, that always happens. They probably Photoshopped about now.
I hope they'll Photoshop it now. See, look at that, like I said. I know. Anyway, those are. Oh, and then I wrote, and this is before, obviously, we ever knew we'd do this podcast. We ever knew that we'd be tracking the Mindy of it all. And this is what I wrote in 2006.
OK. If you're a Kelly fan, you will love this episode. And Mindy, who plays Kelly, does a great job. Hey. Even you knew something special is happening with the character of Kelly in the carpet. 2006 me knew that Kelly was maybe Kelly was maybe Mindy. All right, let's take a break. We'll be back in a sec.
Roll Up to Win is back at Tim Hortons and you've got a shot at millions of prizes like the all new, all electric, 2025 Volkswagen ID Buzz. Play on the Tim's app until March 23rd. Rules apply Canada only. No purchase necessary. Visit the Tim's app for details. This episode is brought to you by RBC Student Banking. POV, you're learning you can get $100 when you open a no monthly fee
RBC Advantage Banking account. Plus, you get unlimited debit transactions in Canada and you can earn Avion points on debit purchases so you can vibe more with friends. POV. You're unlocking more perks for less with RBC. Conditions apply. Offer ends July 2nd, 2025. New eligible clients only. Complete criteria by August 29th, 2025. Visit rbc.com slash student 100. Are you crushing your bills? Defeating your monthly payments. Sounds like you're at the top of your financial game. Rise to it with the BMO Eclipse Rise Visa Card. The credit card that rewards your good financial habits.
Earn points for paying your credit card bill in full and on time every month. Level up from bill payer to reward slayer. Terms and conditions apply. All right, so back to the episode. I have a continuity catch. Okay. At 12 minutes, 43 seconds, Roy and Daryl are removing Michael's carpet.
Okay, they've got this rolled up carpet on their shoulders and they make fun of his dancing. But then at 13 minutes, 12 seconds, there's a shot of them through the blinds in Michael's office and they're having beers and they're kind of sleeping. They're sleeping on the rolled up carpet that they just removed.
They're using it as a headrest. Yeah. Well, there's a continuity catch. Well, I- Unless, is that the new carpet they haven't put down yet? I don't know, but there is a whole deleted scene of just Darryl and Roy just being idiots in that room. There's a whole scene where they are drinking beers and they have two like rubber balls and they're bouncing them against the wall. Like they've got a game going. Yeah. So there were things cut out of this episode of them messing around in there.
Well, I suppose it could be the carpet they haven't installed yet. Maybe. Maybe, Jenna. At 13 minutes, 56 seconds, I declare Michael Sass. Michael Sass, let's hear it. Well, Pam says stopping the sales contest isn't fair. I guess we should say Michael gets upset and he stops his sales contest
No one can win $83 anymore. He's just being a brat, but Michael gives it right back to Pam Oh, yeah. Yeah, I didn't write down what he said, but you can look it up at 13 minutes 56 seconds If you want that sort of takes the wind out of it does I realize I was looking at my sheet I was like, wow, that was an incomplete, I did not complete that question of my homework. Oh, well, I will say this. My sister and I laughed actually. She's a school teacher.
She teaches pre-K and at 14 minutes, 26 seconds, Michael puts the whole office in time out. Oh yes, oh yes. Anyway, okay. So then we have the scene in the kitchen with Jim and Ryan, and Jim asks Ryan what he thinks of Kelly. He's trying to help Kelly out because she's begged him. Well this also just shows where he's at in his day because at first he doesn't want to
help her. He's like, I'm not getting in the middle of those two. And then by the end of the day, he's like, fine, I'll be your go between because he doesn't have his buddy. He doesn't have Pam to help the day pass. Well, we had a fan question. Maddie W. and Adrienne both asked, whose idea was it for Kelly to have a crush on Ryan? What do you think, Angie?
I think it was Mindy's. I don't know. I was going to text her, but she had the Oscars and she was presenting. I didn't want to bug her. Yeah. We were prepping this episode the weekend of Oscars and she was presenting. I didn't want to bug her. Yeah, we were, we were prepping this episode, the weekend of Oscars weekend. Yes. And Mindy was a presenter. And can we talk for one second about how amazing she looked in her dress?
She looked amazing. I actually did text her and BJ the next day and I was like, you guys look so beautiful together. Yeah. And she wrote back, and I love this. Thank you. Well, there you go. Kelly and Ryan went to the Oscars together Well, they're very very dear friend their best friend their best friend There were a lot of friendships that came out of our show. There was our best friendship There was their best friendship. Well, all of the guys still play fantasy football together. That's all the guys every year
All right. So where are we at Jenna? so next Michael talks to Creed about his fear of becoming Ed Truck. Oh, this scene is so funny. Creed made me laugh so hard in this scene. Yeah. He's like, Michael, you have a lot more
to be worried about than that. He's like, oh great, thanks Creed, I guess being buried alive, why am I even talking to you? And then we go outside and we meet Ed Truck. And this scene, ugh, it broke my heart because in the scene, Ed says, Michael, why can't your workers be your workers, your family be your family, and your friends be your friends? And you can see they hold on Michael's face. And you can see that the reason why is because he doesn't have friends and family.
He needs his workers to be all three things. He doesn't have those compartments in his life. No, he doesn't. And it breaks your heart. It breaks your heart for him. Oh, well, speaking of heartbreak, 17 minutes, eight seconds. So this is like cut in between Michael's talking head.
Jim is in the kitchen, which is kind of looks like Jim hung out in the kitchen all day. I think he spent a lot of time in there. Not only that guys, but if you look at this episode, John didn't have very many lines. This was not a tough like line count for him as far as like memory work. All of his stuff was reacting for the most part
in this episode. So, but anyway, during Michael's talking head, we see Jim is in the kitchen and he tries to wave goodbye to Pam. Pam doesn't see it and just leaves. And it's like the last just like wind out of his sails for the day. She kind of leaves early. She's got her big puffy coat on and everyone else is still working, but she sneaks out. Yeah.
And what does he do after that? He calls Brenda. Oh God, it's so desperate. From Booz Cruise, the corporate liaison and asks her on a date. And Kelly's, Mindy's reactions as Kelly to this phone call were so fantastic. So great.
He calls and asks her on a date and then he's like, and you can just, you know, I got your number from the company directory and I guess you could get my number from the company directory. From said directory. Oh, what are you doing, Jim? Or check your email because I just emailed you.
Okay, hope to hear from you. Okay. Yeah, and Kelly's like, did you just ask a girl out over voicemail? He's like, yep. Michael's talking head in this episode, he has a huge talking head that I love and I wrote it all down.
Here it is. Last week, I would have given a kidney to anyone in the office. I would have reached right into my stomach and pulled it out for them. But now, no, I don't have the relationship with these people that I thought I did. I hope they ask.
So they can hear me say, oh, no, I only give my organs to my real friends. Go get yourself a monkey kidney. Oh my God. He's so mad. He's so mad, he's so hurt. He feels so betrayed. He really would have given them one of his organs.
You know he would have. Yeah, he would have. Now he's only gonna give you a monkey kidney. Poor Michael. Poor Michael. And then at 18 minutes 20 seconds, guess who calls? Todd Packer. Todd Packer, did you get that package I left for you? He's like, what package? Did I get package? Anybody see a package? Roy's like, do you mean the thing? The thing in your office? And Michael's delighted. Oh, what a funny prank.
Oh, someone loves me. They want to do jokes. They want to poop on my floor. So funny. When Packer does it, it's a hilarious funny prank. No, when Packer does it, he says at 19 minutes, 13 seconds, it was done out of love. Just like I thought, which is not what he thought.
Oh. It's not what he thought. But I do think he's so relieved that it was no one in the office. Well, everything is right again, right? His universe makes sense again. This is my family. They wouldn't do that.
It's just crazy Todd Packer. Everything's okay. Well, then can we talk about the sweetest of sweet moments? Yes, I did write in my journal. I said, guys, I don't want to give anything away, but this has one of the sweetest endings of an episode yet. So this whole episode, we've given you no indication that Pam is clocking Jim in any way.
In any way. But Jim walks to his desk, he sees the little message light flashing and he plays his messages and Pam has left him seven voicemails all about her day. And clearly she's missing him and missing interacting with him. Yeah. And you see him kind of walk to his car as these messages play. And his face. Oh, he's so happy.
Yeah. And everything is right in his world again. And kind of everything is right in our world again, And kind of everything is right in our world again too, because I think as an audience member, it's funny, I forgot about the voicemail messages when I was watching this. Yeah. And I was frustrated with Pam. I was like, what is wrong with you?
This is your friend, why are you being so coy? I skied a little and then like, say hi to the guy. I wasn't upset with Pam because I feel like she's, this is so complicated for her. I mean, I'm sure there's hills and valleys of her wanting to invest in Roy and what they've built together and see it through. And then there's all these overwhelming feelings of like,
but I don't think he's the right person, but we've been together so long. Like it's, and then when she sees Jim, she's, it's like holding up a mirror to herself. I think it's complicated. But you're telling me she didn't miss him on the vacation. Yes, but admitting to missing him is admitting to this emotional affair and she's not there yet.
She's not there yet, but these messages meant the world to me as a viewer when I was watching it. Yes. I was like, yes, thank you. Thank you. And also guys, once again, I feel like Michael and Jim had a parallel storyline where they sort of lose the thing they love, which is, for Michael,
the acceptance of the office is friends. For Jim, it's Pam. But then in the end, it's all OK. It's going to be OK. Yeah. Aw. Aw. That's the carpet, guys.
That's the carpet, everybody. I have a question. I want to throw it out there. Angela, do we need to start a second podcast where I re-watch Game of Thrones and we discuss it? With me? Yeah, with you. Yes.
Office ladies do Game of Thrones. Oh my gosh. I would love that so much. I mean, I- Does anyone want to hear that? Does anyone want to hear me listen to Game of Thrones? Although, there might be some- Listen to me watch Game of Thrones?
Die Hard Game of Thrones fans will be like, no, you guys are gonna, you're gonna ruin it. All right. Next week we're gonna do Boys and Girls, which is a very exciting episode for Angela and I. We'll tell you all about how we had a hand in creating this episode. Yes. See you next week.
See you next week. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Wise-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Breton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.